okay represent us represent dot us is
the website Josh silver longtime friend
of the show formerly founder of Free
Press based near the original home of
the David Pakman show
in Florence Massachusetts has launched
his new endeavor is represent us and
they are working on pointing out when
there is corruption in our political
system as you can imagine the answer is
basically all the time so they're very
very busy as you know the FCC now run by
former Verizon lawyer Ajit PI an
appointment of President Donald Trump
the FCC is actively working on repealing
net neutrality not a salacious issue but
could not possibly be more important
Internet freedom diversity of ideas
political dissent of endless importance
right now so far eight members of
Congress have publicly backed the FCC's
plan to repeal net neutrality by signing
a statement of support or by having
their statements included in an industry
written Republican talking points
document now you don't actually need as
the FCC that is you don't need
congressional support to repeal net
neutrality but they want it because the
optics of doing it only based on what
Internet service providers want wouldn't
look that great
so the optics are particularly bad right
now also because as I mentioned Ajit PI
is a former Verizon lobbyist so
represent us look at the lobbying money
that the eight supporters received from
the telecom industry and it is bad from
companies and other organizations in the
telecom industry this includes companies
like Comcast the NCTA which is a cable
lobby telephone utilities they looked at
all of those contributions together and
it is pathetic and embarrassing and
corrupt take a look at this Greg Walden
received nearly 1.3 million dollars he's
a Republican from Oregon these are all
Republicans congresswoman Marsha
Blackburn received six hundred and
twenty thousand dollars Senator John
Thune five hundred and sixty two
thousand dollars senator Roger wicker
four hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars Paul Ryan over half
a million dollars congresswoman cathy
McMorris Rogers $519,000 Tom graves and
bob latta a hundred and seventy-six and
four hundred and twenty three thousand
dollars respectively a total Pat of over
4.5 million dollars from the telecom
companies and lobbyists to the eight
members of Congress all Republicans many
of them at the forefront of other gifts
to Internet service providers in telecom
companies like supporting their ability
to sell our browsing data supporting
prior attempts to kill net neutrality a
direct line between the money and the
industry and their positions on the
repeal of net neutrality it is
disgusting and it is all legal Pat that
is the horrible part yeah and you wonder
why Republicans and the FCC now are
hell-bent on ending net neutrality as we
know it it goes back to money in
politics it's the root of all evil and
despite the fact that if you look at the
polling I think a recent morning console
poll found 61% of people want to keep
the net neutrality laws I think that
number would be higher by the way if
more people knew without a tell with me
on to it despite all that they're still
going to go through with this Donald
Trump said we need to stop Muslim
immigration to the US until we can
figure out what the hell is going on we
need to stop the repeal of net
neutrality until the average voter can
figure out what the hell is going on
and why it is that big corporations want
net neutrality repealed because this is
it connects you know when we us to
pointed out that money in politics
connects to so many of the issues that
we are dealing with Internet freedom
connect to so many of the issues that
we're dealing with whether it's
reproductive rights or education or
global warming climate change whatever
the case may be where are people by and
large finding things out about issues
that are important to them the internet
there is arguably behind money in
politics no more important issue
whatever your key issues of importance
are than Internet freedom
and this is an issue of corruption
progressives need to appeal to
Republicans on this because right now
Donald Trump and Republicans are
controlling the White House in the
Senate and the White House so maybe
Republicans think they don't care about
it but the tide will go the other way
and this type of freedom is paramount to
us getting a variety of information
about whatever issues are important to
us it's one of those things that
actually can be bipartisan and another
point of this another part of this issue
is the fact that the media won't really
cover it because of course they're too
tied into these telecom company no doubt
about it no doubt about it you are
barely going to hear a word about it on
corporate media it's disgusting what's
going on